[Música]
cuerpos policiales y medios de
comunicación ucranianos regresan a
gerson la ciudad vuelve a estar bajo
control de kiev tras La retirada del
ejército de Moscú según el kremlin No
quedan tropas rusas a la orilla oeste
del Río nieper
a los demócratas les falta un escaño
para conseguir la mayoría en el senado
el demócrata Mark Kelly fue reelegido
senador por el estado de Arizona al
derrotar al republicano Blake Masters
Aliado del ex presidente Trump el
control de la cámara alta depende ahora
de Nevada y Georgia
el presidente de Bolivia Luis Arce
mantiene el censo poblacional para 2014
el registro actual será el vigente para
las elecciones de 2025 la oposición
protesta en las calles de Santa Cruz ya
que pide que el censo se renueve en 2023
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania
porque tras La retirada de las tropas
rusas avanza la retoma ucraniana de
gerson ayer viernes las fuerzas
especiales de kiev fueron los primeros
en ingresar a la ciudad abandonada por
los rusos y esta mañana Ya entraron 200
policías volvieron a emitir estaciones
de radio y televisión y empezó a llegar
ayuda humanitaria desde nikolaive anoche
decenas de personas en toda Ucrania
celebraron el que es el mayor repliegue
organizado de las fuerzas de Moscú desde
que se retiraron de la región de kiev la
capital sin embargo el kremlin insistió
ayer en que su salida militar de la urbe
no cambia el estatus de la región
anexada ilegalmente por Rusia
la celebración de una reconquista El
regreso del ejército ucraniano a la
ciudad de gerson ha sido catalogado como
la mayor victoria de kiev desde que
inició la invasión hace ocho meses Rusia
dijo que retiró a más de 30.000
militares de la urbe hacia la otra
orilla del río
niépers
los ciudadanos esperaron nunca
repudiaron a Ucrania tenían razón al
depositar sus esperanzas en Ucrania y
Ucrania siempre devuelve las suyas me
alegra ver a esa gente a pesar de todos
los peligros la represión y el
sufrimiento infligido por los ocupantes
que se aferran a las banderas ucranianas
en el centro de kiev cientos se
reunieron el viernes por la noche para
celebrar la noticia muchos son
originarios de gerson pero que huyeron
cuando las fuerzas rusas los invadieron
en marzo
Ginger son muchos empiezan a regresar a
sus hogares o lo que queda de ellos los
rusos destruyeron y saquearon casas pero
no todo se fueron como esta granjera que
recuerdan los angustiosos momentos que
vivió durante la ocupación
no el camino
nos dan con las culatas de los rifles
los rusos dañaron las casas de los que
sirvieron a su ejército y se llevaron
los bienes de las mejores casas
jerson fue la única gran ciudad
ucraniana en caer en manos enemigas
Rusia sigue controlando alrededor del
60% de la región que lleva el mismo
nombre incluida la costa del mar de azul
y que fue anexionada ilegalmente junto a
otras tres por Moscú el principal punto
de acceso a la ciudad cruzando el río
niéper era el puente anthonynski ahora
destruido según lo confirmado por
imágenes satelitales imágenes que
también señalan nuevos daños en La
Represa de Nueva kahofka al norte de
gerson y cuya eventual voladura
generaría desastrosas inundaciones en el
país
vamos ahora a Camboya donde se
desarrolla la Cumbre de la sean la
asociación de Naciones del sureste
asiático a la que asistió hoy el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
la guerra en Ucrania marcó las
conversaciones el ministro de relaciones
exteriores ucraniano dimitro kuleva
pidió a los países asiáticos que tomen
todas las medidas posibles para que
Rusia detenga lo que calificó como los
Juegos del Hambre con el mundo sin
embargo el foco de la Cumbre es la
crisis de myanmar el propio presidente
biden afirmó que Washington trabajará en
el retorno de la Democracia myanmar
recordemos que el país está sumido en
una guerra civil desde el golpe militar
de febrero de 2021
Camboya es la penúltima parada del viaje
Express del presidente estadounidense en
el centro de los debates La amenaza
nuclear norcoreana pero también Taiwán y
China un preludio de la reunión entre
Joe biden y
dentro de unos días en el marco del g20
otro tema importante el estancamiento de
la crisis en nyanmark el líder de la
junta no fue invitado por segundo año
consecutivo una ausencia que delata la
falta de avances en las conversaciones
para resolver la crisis muchos líderes
asiáticos y el secretario general de la
ONU afirman que la junta no va a cumplir
sus objetivos de restablecer la paz
de violencia el uso desproporcionado de
la fuerza y la terrible situación de los
Derechos Humanos en miamar los ataques
indiscriminados contra civiles pueden
constituir crímenes de guerra según el
derecho internacional
este año la asociación de Naciones del
sur está asiático va más allá los
líderes quieren involucrar a los grupos
de oposición de myanmar en el proceso de
paz esto ha provocado La era de la junta
gobernante que considera a sus
opositores como terroristas las
organizaciones humanitarias también
denuncian las acciones de la junta
Por las luchas geopolíticas entre
Estados Unidos y chinas sobre la
cuestión de myanmar pero los dirigentes
se olvidan de que miles de personas han
perdido la vida a manos de esta junta
diabólica Y seguirán perdiéndola
mientras las sean siga paralizada
no es conocida por sus posturas
divisivas pero este año se está
endureciendo e incluso se está
considerando excluir a los
representantes de myanmar por completo
si la situación lo justifica vamos ahora
a Estados Unidos porque el ex presidente
Donald Trump presentó una demanda contra
el comité del Congreso que Investiga el
asalto al capitorio del 6 de enero de
2021 con la demanda Trump pretende ganar
tiempo para evitar acudir a la citación
que lo obliga a testificar ante el
comité cuyo mandato termina a final de
este año 2022 la demanda sostiene que si
bien en el pasado exmandatarios
brindaron testimonio o documentos en
respuesta a citaciones del Congreso
ningún presidente o ex presidente se vio
obligado a hacerlo cito textualmente el
precedente y la práctica arraigados
sostienen que la separación de poderes
prohíbe al congreso obligar a un
presidente a testificar ante él dijo el
abogado de Trump en un comunicado
y continuamos en Estados Unidos pero
vamos ahora con noticias sobre el avance
del conteo de los resultados de las
elecciones de medio término del pasado
martes 8 mientras los republicanos están
a siete escaños de lograr la mayoría en
la cámara de representantes los
demócratas necesitan solo un escaño para
hacerse con el control del senado allí
en la cámara alta ambos partidos cuentan
ahora con 49 senadores por lo que la
atención está puesta en el conteo del
estado de Nevada el único que no
oficializó todavía sus resultados una
victoria demócrata en Nevada daría el
partido de Joe biden el control del
senado contando con el voto de desempate
de kamala Harris
los demócratas están muy cerca de lograr
mantener el control del senado 4 días
después de la fecha oficial de la
elección Se confirmó la victoria de Mark
Kelly en el estado de Arizona resultó
reelecto y superó a republicano Blake
Masters Aliado del ex presidente Donald
Trump así las cosas ambos partidos
tienen ahora 49 escaños y ahora el
control de la cámara alta se juega en
dos estados claves Nevada y Georgia
Nevada todavía no pudo oficializar los
resultados allí es republicano Adam
laxol tiene una muy estrecha ventaja
sobre su adversaria Katherine cortes más
tú en este estado sábado es el último
día para recibir votos por correo lo que
explica el retraso
hacemos todo lo que está en nuestras
manos para que las papeletas avancen lo
más rápido posible pero con los plazos
que tenemos no puedo terminar el conteo
hasta que lleguen todos los correos es
un número muy pequeño pero aún así no
puedo terminar antes del sábado
en caso de reelección para la candidata
demócrata el partido de Mont tendría su
control del senado con 50 escaños ya que
el voto de desempate recae sobre la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris pero en
caso de Victoria republicana Nevada el
futuro del senado se jugará nuevamente
en el estado de Georgia donde una
segunda vuelta se celebrará el 6 de
diciembre entre el demócrata Rafael
Warner y ya no se publican Walker se
espera una feroz batalla final con una
avalanza de fondos de campaña lejos de
la marea roja augurada por las encuestas
los republicanos están ahora a sólo
siete escaños de quedarse con una muy
estrecha mayoría en la cámara de
representantes
vamos ahora con noticias de nuestra
región porque en Bolivia este viernes el
presidente Luis Arce mantuvo el censo
poblacional para 2024 lo que mantendría
el registro actual para las próximas
elecciones la oposición protesta en las
calles de Santa Cruz ya que pide que el
censo se renueve en 2023 y así disponer
de más recursos y más diputados para los
comicios de 2025 informa y es Muñoz
la tensión se mantienen las calles de
Santa Cruz mientras el gobierno
boliviano no da su brazo a torcer y
mantiene el censo poblacional y de
vivienda para el 23 de marzo de 2024 el
presidente Luis Arce hizo un llamado a
la calma las bolivianas y bolivianos
queremos vivir en paz somos de la
cultura del diálogo y de la paz y por
eso llamamos a pacificar entre todas y
todos
el viernes se cumplían tres semanas de
protestas es el plazo que dio la
oposición de Santa Cruz para convocar el
censo poblacional en 2023 Durante este
tiempo ha habido cuatro muertos y más de
100 heridos se acabe
[Aplausos]
n los que están con el pueblo qué es lo
que Todos queremos el último censo se
realizó en 2012 el gobierno de Luis Arce
lo retrasó de 2023 a 2024 alegando el
parón de la pandemia además de bastión
opositor Santa Cruz es la segunda ciudad
del país y el principal centro económico
es la mayor receptora de migración
interna por lo que el aumento de
población le otorgaría más recursos de
hacerse el censo en 2023 la región
tendría tres diputados más en la
asamblea para las elecciones de 2025 Sin
embargo esta protesta se limita a Santa
Cruz y no tiene apoyo en el resto del
país tampoco es un apoyo masivo de forma
interna Ya que el movimiento al
socialismo es el segundo partido más
apoyado en la región
no nos dejan circular no nos dejan pagar
no deja de hacer nada Santa Cruz fue
también en 2019 el lugar desde donde se
ideó el derrocamiento del gobierno de
Evo Morales
y en una semana empieza el mundial de
fútbol de Qatar y la selección ganadora
de la competición levantará la copa del
mundo el próximo 18 de diciembre el
italiano Silvio gatzanica diseñó el
icónico trofeo en 1971 Y actualmente una
empresa con base en Milán Italia es la
encargada de esculpirlo en el siguiente
informe Andrés triviño nos cuenta el
proceso de elaboración de uno de los
premios más codiciados del planeta
anhelado y codiciado por todas las
elecciones del mundo además de la
emoción que genera el mundial uno de sus
mayores atractivos es la pieza que se
lleva el equipo ganador un trofeo que
pocos han podido tener en sus manos fue
diseñado por el escultor italiano Silvio
gatzaniga en 1971 tiene dos figuras
humanas sosteniendo la tierra que
representan tocar la gloria y tener el
mundo en las manos
cuando el diseñador Silvio gazaniga
estaba comenzando a desarrollar la forma
de expresar este icono deportivo también
estaba pensando en cómo el ganador tenía
que usarlo frente a la cámara y así fue
comenzando un camino que realmente puede
mantenerlo en las manos y elevarse como
una copa en una ceremonia esa fue una
forma de expresar el amor por el deporte
y la confianza en el deporte desde 1974
este icónico premio es entregado cada
cuatro años al monarca del mundial del
fútbol y en esta edición será levantado
en Qatar el 18 de de diciembre la firma
gde bertoni es la encargada de pulir el
trofeo de oro de 18 quilates que pesa un
poco más de 6 kilos mide 36.8
centímetros y su precio ronda entre los
250.000 y los 300.000 dólares una vez se
juega el último partido del mundial el
nombre de la selección ganadora es
inscripto en la base del trofeo y luego
entregada en la ceremonia de premiación
Posteriormente la federación de dicho
país recibe una réplica y es exhibida
ante el público mientras que la original
es retornada la FIFA quien se encarga de
resguardarla hasta la próxima edición
cuando el trofeo regresa lo volvemos a
bañar en oro arreglamos las pequeñas
ralladuras de la malaquita y grabamos la
base con el nombre del equipo ganador
este pequeño equipo de escultores
también produce varios de los trofeos
más famosos del deporte como los de la
UEFA Champions League o la copa africana
de Naciones haciendo llegar a millones
con la victoria
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en France 24 y 24.com
[Música]